c'est un enjeu essentiel que celui de
l'intelligence artificielle qui est un
enjeu qui ne se limite pas à la
génération de faux contenus qui est ce
qui intéresse le plus la discussion
publique actuellement mais il y a
beaucoup de choses que l'on ne voit pas
aisément qui sont beaucoup plus
dommageables à nos démocraties notamment
le recours à des outils d'intelligence
artificielle pour détecter
automatiquement des failles dans nos
systèmes d'information des failles
qu'exploitent par exemple des pirates
informatiques pour perturber le
fonctionnement de système adverse et le
gardien a des a révélé il y a de jours
la pénétration de de système d'une
centrale nucléaire britannique par des
hackurs agissant pour la Chine et la
Russie ces détections des failles ne se
limitent pas au
système structurel mais également au
faille de nos esprits et l'une des
particularités de l'intelligence
artificielle telle qu'elle est utilisée
aujourd'hui d'ors et déjà par les
plateforme numérique quelle qu'ell soit
et l'exploitation de l'analyse
prédictive de la personnalité à des fins
de microciiblage publicitaire et parfois
d'exploitation subversive des failles de
nos esprits par certains acteurs
malveillants pour produire des effets
parfois dommageables pour nos sociétés
il y a enfin cette question de la
génération de faux contenus qui pose un
problème systémique dans la mesure où
les progrès de l'intelligence
artificielle sont des progrès
exponentiels qui nécessairement devrait
conduire prochainement à une situation
fort désagréable dans laquelle le faux
primera quantitativement sur le vrai
dans l'environnement informationnel ce
qui aura des effets en retour tous les
systèmes par exemple les systèmes de
moteur de recherche qui reposent sur une
approche inductive c'est-à-dire
statistiquement détermine le vrai en
fonction de ce l'information qui domine
la terre est ronde parce que la plupart
des gens sur Internet affirment qu'elle
est ronde si un
jour l'information selon laquelle elle
est PL domine un système de ce type
pourrait à une question posée par un
utilisateur répondre bien sûr la terre
est plate autrement dit ce problème est
systémique